es uno de los argumentos esgrimidos por
el gobierno para justificar su reforma
pensional
la edad legal de jubilación en Francia
es una de las más bajas en Europa 62
años en la actualidad lejos de sus
vecinos España y Alemania que encabezan
la lista en 2007 y 2030 respectivamente
la edad para pensionarse será 67 una
realidad que ya existe en Italia y
Dinamarca países en los que la edad
legal de jubilación se retrasa
regularmente a medida que aumenta la
esperanza de vida por tanto los
franceses tendrán que equipararse con el
resto del continente Porque hasta la
fecha sólo los trabajadores griegos y
suecos pueden jubilarse la misma edad
que Los Galos a los 62 en Suecia se ha
establecido un sistema de puntos Cuanto
más trabajas más acumulas
otros países como Austria y Polonia
permiten a las mujeres jubilarse antes
allí pueden dejar de trabajar a los 60
años y en el caso de los hombres a los